oh hey guys check out my robot socks
pretty sweet huh
so guys I was farting around on YouTube
the other day and I came across this
now you can relieve inflamed
hemorrhoidal tissue with the oxygen
action of preparation-h what that's
Bryan Cranston Eisenberg selling what
medicine and then YouTube started
suggesting videos when I clicked another
one and saw this
Brad Pitt selling Pringles in what
universe so that got me thinking we
probably find other celebrities doing
embarrassing crap to make a couple of
bucks before they blow up and become
mega stars so let's watch some
commercials from will decide are we
using it or losing it ok can you
recognize who this fresh-faced teenager
is hi oh yeah yeah this is Burger King
it's Ben Affleck our next Batman there
is so much wrong with this commercial
first off who calls Burger King for
delivery
would you take a chef's salad is this
your first time ever trying restaurants
this commercial is misleading Burger
King doesn't deliver your food and top
it all off Ben Affleck should not be
Batman that has nothing to do with this
but I'm saying it anyway
losing it this next one features Bruce
Willis who's been kind of a curmudgeon
lately but anything but a curmudgeon in
this check it out
Comstock
has anyone seen Bruce Willis this happy
in decades the guy needs to start
drinking the wine coolers again look at
him he's going crazies loves it he's
singing oh man start drinking the wine
coolers again Bruce maybe you'll win an
Oscar
maybe you'll get Demi Moore back who
wants her you know what you could steal
Mila Kunis from Ashton Kutcher hi Ardoin
yes Willis do it but still losing it
wine coolers suck alright this next
commercial features a guy who whacks to
my legs
Paul Rudd at such a gentle touch so I
was delighted to see him here when you
decide to get serious there's only one
place to come the games of Super
Nintendo look at these graphics I want
to play those games again I'm gonna go
on eBay and buy a Super NES Plus this
commercial looks way better than Paul
Rudd's movie this is 40 using it so
Bryan Cranston didn't just do
preparation-h to pay the bills he also
did this other one that blew my mind he
used to start the day showering with
ordinary soap I tried a ton a day was
over he had a problem that's Walter
White in a skunk suit if you smell that
bad at the end of the day that's not a
soap issue that's a medical issue you
need to see an a damn doctor but clearly
I am using the out of that so can
you guess who this apathetic aunjanue is
dad I missed the bus that's right it's
Twilight mouth-breather Kristen Stewart
before she was staring blankly on the
set of Twilight she was staring blankly
on the set of Porsche commercials I am
not loving this ad I don't like that
Kristen Stewart is a dirty little liar
she intentionally missed the bus she's
got the awesome experience of riding in
a Porsche to school and pulling up in
school getting out be like bye dad my
dad drove a speaker to school that I was
embarrassed my cat trophy to school that
box clearly losing it the next one
features Frodo himself Elijah Wood
Hawking cheese away cuz cheddar cheese
makes all the difference
all right before he was dealing with the
CGI of Mordor and orcs he was dealing
with CGI cheese but his acting as little
kid was pretty good and that cheese
broccoli looks awesome using it this
commercial features Morgan Freeman what
do you think of the taste of Listerine
Tara oh I'm trying others they don't
taste as bad so I stick to Listerine why
are they interrupting workers doing a
dangerous job up on brown powerlines hub
Morgan Freeman died Oh some guy was
asking about mouthwash
he got 30,000 volts rocketing through
his body not only that it's like the
angle that the mouthwash takes to sell
itself that were terrible tasting I
think if it didn't taste so strong it
wouldn't be working but because of that
honesty I'm using it but a Papa I'm
loving this commercial could be the best
tasting lettuce and tomato hamburger
ever DLT Jason Alexander George Costanza
from Seinfeld with hair when did he have
that weird hair can you believe this
packaging it's double styrofoam boxes
but she's the lettuce cool and the
burger Haut yes count me in the trees
thing to bring us back I'm buying it
this next one isn't an episode of Joey
it's a Heinz ketchup commercial
featuring Matt LeBlanc hot dog
you don't add it what no thanks I got a
cup Heinz ketchup it's so rich so thick
wine waste time with anything else I
like to imagine a little breeze blowing
that bottle slightly and it rolls off
and strikes a bystander in the head ah
as a ketchup or blood I don't know let's
catch up using it so did we miss any
cooler embarassing old celebrity
commercials let us know in the comments
section below best answer gets a $25
gift card from Best Buy
brought to you by cinema now from Best
Buy I want to thank you for watching I'm
Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye bye
hey guys Hal here next week is our
one-year anniversary how should we
celebrate it who should we bring back
tell us in the comments below if we do
your idea we'll send you screen junkies
t-shirt that's how that works
thanks for watching everybody I like